[Music]
on beautiful ni
you
nice you're making a
mess there was a some of the little
girls from the ex department and stuff
were out there feeding them an or uh
apples all morning yeah they're probably
are you are you all tired of apples
should I brought you some I don't think
you can ever get completely tired of
them but
write something else
[Music]
swe just taking little BT you're such a
lady such a lady
here wipe your hands on my chests there
you
go
you okay so let's let's go through this
a couple of times if you don't mind um
M want just take a step back take a step
back let George have the horse go down
and turn the horse guys give us a little
room back off